i have seriously fallen in love with
yamato's character after only 17
chapters not only do i love the entirety
of her character design but i also think
that she's had an incredibly
refreshing and enjoyable impact on the
story and so i've been enjoying pretty
much
every single moment with her in the
story so far honestly i've always
thought i'd be immune to fanboying for a
specific character
but i've been proven wrong luckily turns
out that i'm not the only one who thinks
that way and if you know me
simply saying that a character is cool
isn't satisfying for me and
if you don't know me hi my name is ohara
and in this video
i want to explore with you what made
yamato so lovable as a character
in such a short span of time and why i
personally believe that she should be
the next straw hats
but first things first i can already
hear people typing comments about me
using
her in the intro and even though i'd
love to jump right into all the awesome
things that i like about yamato i want
to clear this up first luckily enough
however
i think that this debate is actually a
pretty big part of what makes a
character designer personality
so interesting so here's my take on why
i believe that yamato is one of the best
female characters in the story now of
course i'm not claiming to be
objectively right here but
as of now this is my perspective i
strongly believe that people should be
able to freely identify the way that
they see themselves
and since we sadly still live in a world
where there's a lot of discrimination
and stigmatization
not only in the context of gender but
also when it comes to things like race
i also think that it's important to
stand up against intolerance
so everyone has the chance to be who
they are and so
having this sort of debate is important
periods
now that being said however when people
get upset about yamato being called a
her
i think they're missing the fundamental
point of her character for comparison
take someone like kiku
here we have someone that clearly is
stating that they are a woman at heart
a very uncontroversial statement about
kiku seeing herself as a woman
case closed with yamato on the other
hand the context is fundamentally
different
now the reason for this entire
controversy is that yamato calls herself
kaido
sun and also uses the pronoun boku which
is predominantly used by boys in japan
[Music]
now bulk in itself however is in no way
exclusive to boys and is actually quite
often used by girls as well
to not appear too girly the truly male
pronoun to use would be ode
that is used way rare among girls and
has a sort of tough guy connotation and
in any case
pronouns in japan these days are much
more a statement about personality
than about gender the much bigger point
in my opinion however is the fact that
yamato
clearly doesn't want to be a guy she
wants to be
odin yamato is literally role-playing
odin
not because he's a chat which by the way
he 100
[Music]
is
but because of his ideals and his
personality i think it's pretty clear
that the true struggle yamato has with
her identity is
not a matter of gender but of morality
she's literally being held captive by
her father who killed the very man she
idealizes
her real identity crisis is all about
finding a way to fight for her dream to
leave wano
make friends and see the world and so
taking on odin's persona
is a way for her to both keep his and
her dreams alive
while at the same time fleeing the
tragic nature of her own miserable life
now time will prove me right or wrong
here but i
strongly believe that a large chunk of
yamato's arc during wano
will be about embracing who she truly is
and being able to let go of odin
as an ideal to cling to and again since
none of this has
anything to do with gender in my opinion
i think it's not only tolerable to call
yama to her
i'd actually say that it's a great thing
when you consider that the number of
women in one piece that can actually
keep up with the men
are very few and far between indeed
yamato being as strong as she is and
having the guts and stamina that usually
are reserved for oda's alpha males in my
eyes makes her a refreshingly dominant
female character
in fact oda was inspired for yamatos by
the character
oscar from a shoujo manga the rose of
versailles a woman raised by her father
as if she were a boy in order to succeed
him as the commander of the royal guard
at the palace of versailles a concept
that oda found
very intriguing as he mentioned in his
notes on chapter 945
and i have to 100 agree with that point
having yamato take on odin's identity
has been a major part of her charm
in more than just one way i think okay
so with that out of the way
let's talk about yamato's character
first of all just
visually alone i think she's absolutely
unique
white hair the beautiful face and the
red horns together with the traditional
japanese outfit she's wearing
make her one of my favorite visual
designs in the story
i think everything here just really fits
the name yamato by the way is actually a
very old term for japan itself
roughly translating to harmony which
when you think about it both in a way
fits perfectly and
not at all at the same time now the fact
that she's the main villain's daughter
that has allied with luffy is an
incredibly refreshing and interesting
concept in my opinion
that instantaneously added so many more
layers to the plots
and also to kaido himself what is their
true relationship
how does kaido feel about her what does
it mean for her role in the war
just a fantastic puzzle piece that gave
us so many new options in this already
epic arc
and i think it's great that while she
clearly dislikes her father
she nonetheless shares a lot of
similarities with him
[Music]
her direct and imposing manner her
fighting style that also includes a huge
iron club as well as several of kaido's
own techniques
that he clearly must have taught her
personally
and finally her wild and beast-like vibe
that of course
also includes an animal transformation
in many ways her character is a great
twist on the typical
princess trope yes she is a caged bird
that has to be freed by our hero from
the claws of the villain but she's
pretty much the exact opposite of being
all whiny and fragile
in fact she's actually really really
strong just not
quite strong enough to deal with her
yonko father now i personally think that
in many ways
what makes yamato so incredibly
relatable and refreshing in the story
is that she often feels like a female
version of luffy with
all the things we love about him his
strong will
[Music]
his altruism his sturdiness
and also his naivety and quirkiness
all of them can also be found in yamato
and i think that's why
so many people including myself
immediately resonated with her character
and as a result yamato feels very
organic and despite her quick
introduction
to the story it kind of seems like she's
been around forever
which actually brings me to the most
pressing question about her
will yamato join the crew now if i had
to bet money on it
i would say yes not only because i
really
really want this to happen but also
because yamato fulfills all the
requirements for a new crew member
perfectly actually almost a bit too
perfectly to be precise
first of all we have the dream as we
have already established
yamato wants to travel the world just
like odin did
so not only do we have a dream here but
as with all the straw hats we have an
inherited dream inherited will not only
from odin but also from ace secondly
while we've only gotten parts of it so
far
we already know that yamato has had a
very tragic past
being held captive by her father and
shielded from the world
and even more importantly luffy is the
one who can save her and give her a path
forward
something also shared by all other straw
hats the fact that she's powerful enough
to also fight with the crew and that she
knows about the importance of finding
love tail
are just cherries on top at this point
oh yeah and did i mention that she
actually asked luffy to join
i'm 100 convinced that she will play a
major role in this battle
and i can just cross my fingers that my
new favorite female character
will join luffy on his journey put
yamato for nakama in the comments if you
agree
peace